the live and Alive tour is off and
running Springfield Missouri September
1st and 2nd Tulsa Oklahoma September
15th and 16th Phoenix Arizona September
29th and 30th get your tickets to all
shows at ryansickler.com
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the new night pass
Studios I'm Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler on all your
social media I want to say thank you
thank you so much for watching this show
sharing this show telling people about
this show we're up in over 200 000
subscribers now on YouTube we're up over
5 000 on patreon I can't thank you
enough watching this community grow has
been pretty wild man
um so if you haven't subscribed
subscribe it helps the show
um and if you gotta have more then you
gotta check out the patreon every week
on the Honeydew with y'all we hear
something that I just I really I'm not
gonna lie to you every week I sit down
I'm like there's no way we're gonna hear
some some stuff that we haven't already
heard or whatever and then we hear like
for instance
um this cup this eyes college roommate
on spring break went home just decided
to wipe out his whole family killed his
entire family why well because he was
going to kill all the guys in his house
but he overslept they got up went to
work so he went and killed his own
family that's a story we also have a
story of an elderly couple who was taken
hostage by a dude that just killed his
own friend on the highway had them in
the house all day long the old man
he gets loose homeboy's got a gun under
the seat what does he do
subscribe and find out five dollars a
month you sign up for a year you get
over a month of episodes for free you
also get the Honeydew a day early you
get it ad free you get it at no
additional cost it's a cup of coffee not
just for one episode we've got I don't
even know there's well over 100 episodes
there now so go check that out
um and listen if you're list looking for
a new podcast to listen to I'm telling
you go listen to my old podcast to crab
Feast it's all fun storytelling with
everybody you know in comedy
um and that Community is crazy it's
still going after all these years it's a
podcast I did with Jay Larson everybody
you know and loves Bill Burr Tom segor
Burke Chrysler Christina P they're all
on there with different stories
everybody you like
um And subscribe to that all right now
tour dates if I'm in your town when
you're around please come out and see me
uh let's see September 1st and 2nd is
Springfield Missouri September 15th and
16th is Tulsa Oklahoma September 29th
and 30th I'm gonna be back in Phoenix
October 27th and 28th is Salt Lake City
and then December 8th and 9th I'm back
in San Francisco all tickets are
available at Ryan sickler.com all right
that's the business now you know what
we're doing over here I always say uh
these are the stories behind the
storytellers and we're going to
highlight the low lights this week y'all
with the return of Joe list welcome back
to the Honeydew Joseph thank you very
much I'm so excited dude thank you for
being patient through that of course I
appreciate it I enjoyed it I gotta get
on the goddamn patreon you told me some
other stories off camera that I'm like
this is the most insane thing 18 year
old Cold Case salt we had the double
lung transplant we've had a girl with
two [__]
um we had a lady with I think it was up
to four [__] we've had we had a dude
that survived the uh a bombing uh we've
had military guys we've had people
who've died and come back since it's in
it's a wild show it's a wild show you
just describe my family four [__]
two [__] military and surviving a
bombing
oh [__] uh well before we get into
whatever we're going to talk about today
please plug and promote everything Joe
list yeah
comediangelist.com to the camera or to
you what do I do wherever you like shot
this is you right here if you want to go
wide hit him right there Joe life folks
um I'm gonna switch back and forth
really do some work for you yeah do your
live switching yeah uh yeah comediennejo
list.com for dates and uh I have a new
special it's out right now on YouTube
called enough for everybody and there's
another one there's three one's called I
hate myself one's called this year's
material and one's called enough for
everybody which just came out so go
watch it like subscribe all those things
how are you um how what what's when's
the last special you put up uh how long
in between it's been three in like three
years three and a half years one came
out I can't remember the dates one came
out in 2020 I guess summer of 2020. and
then one came out last year February of
2022 I think or April of 2022 and then
now August of 2023. where'd you shoot
this one all they're all shot at the
village underground
right yeah I just keep doing the same
thing I'm like let's just set me up
again with that one and for a while I
was like maybe I'll do a Trilogy of
village underground specials and then I
shot this one I was like maybe I'll just
keep doing it here who cares because
it's it's intimate it's home and it
feels and to being a special everyone's
like wow the background and you can't
just keep shooting in the same place and
I'm like well why not who cares the joke
the jokes are the special what
difference does it make if I'm in a
different room do I talk about this all
the time when people talk about like
production value I was just saying like
you you complimented the studio and
thank you very much but going to New
York like it just seems so much more
relax and chill I didn't look at it as
low budget or anything I was like ah
this is what how podcasting started it
was at tables and apartments and right
some people did them in their cars or
wherever and then it got elevated to
these Studios and things like that but
if you go back and the one example I
really love is Chappelle Show when you
go back to the um Rick James sketch they
didn't bother to even put something on
the green screen right it's green screen
right they didn't bother to just click a
frame of anything yeah when he's in the
room and he's uh tearing up the couch
it's it's four Black Walls it's a wooden
window Acro on a black wall it's not
even a real window and there's a mirror
it's like there's nothing in there but
all you remember is the comedy of that
whole [__] thing that's how I feel
and uh but yeah I'm glad you're saying
this because I do Tuesdays with stories
with Mark Norman another plug funny
podcast the funniest I think and um
we got oh yeah he's the best but we got
we're in like an office space it's like
four by six and we we like taped like
glue out of like uh whatever you call
like a toothpaste thing of glue and just
jammed wallpaper and it's all coming
down and everyone's like you guys suck
get a real Studio not everybody but
several people yeah and we're like but
just listen we're just talking who cares
that's how I feel but you guys do it
right I mean this looks amazing that's
nice this is uh I hope I'm saying his
name Ray is it Ted muns
10 months he makes these podcast signs
for so many podcasts out there uh bad
friends hey babe he's just they're
everywhere this dude's Work is sick yeah
it looks awesome it's sick go check them
out on Instagram
um let's talk about you so before uh we
sat down you told me that you and your
wife are expecting this is your first
child yeah first child uh it's scary
because we're very old my wife is 68
years
um
[Music]
you know what's crazy I have my aunt my
aunt's kid is yeah she's like 20 and
she's about to have a kid
and my uncle's wife and my wife is
having a kid and they're due a day apart
and my uncle's wife is younger than my
wife so she's gonna become a grandmother
the day after my wife becomes a mother
and she's older
if that makes sense it's it does yes
we wait cause we're in Showbiz first of
all I'm 41. okay
45. your wife's 45 yeah she's older than
me and
well honestly like
I was
41 when my daughter was born it's 40
when we got 41 when my daughter was born
that makes me feel good yeah I feel old
and you don't seem old dude I almost
just died you're fine trust me what do
you mean I had this whole ordeal yeah
it's all good I want to hear it but it
was a month I spent the month in the
hospital uh of January in the hospital
and heart trouble I I had it wasn't my
fault it was Hospital trouble all right
I wasn't supposed that wasn't supposed
to happen I petrified of heart I went
for a back surgery and then I laid they
let me lay so long that I clawed and I
almost died it was a whole ordeal so now
I spent the month there but
um you're fine trust me you look like
you're in great shape thank you you're
you're uh and 45 I mean these days I
feel like with all the advancement in
medicine and everything it's not a big
deal well my wife is extremely healthy
too she eats very healthy I don't she
works out all that [__] and she has good
genes I mean her dad died at 51 but all
right
[Music]
but uh yeah I think she's healthy and
I'm younger than her and uh you know a
kid only really needs parents for what
10 years then they're fine a little
longer than that all right 18 20. um but
they only do need love from one that's
what all the therapists have told me
probably lied to me to keep me coming
and get my checks just in case you ever
want to check out oh geez um all right
well she's very cold so I'll give them
all the love so 45 is your wife is
concerned as you are no I don't think so
I don't think so she's not as uh openly
neurotic as I am she's not like telling
you I'm really nervous I'm 45 and she's
not putting that out there are you
putting that out there to her or is this
just your anxiety I keep telling her
you're old as [__] baby you look at you
uh you look terrible do you say that in
a nicer way no no do you express concern
uh I'm like slightly concerned it's hard
I guess you know like when you have a
okay you start doing math I think also
when you get to your 40s like because
I'm like okay when I'm
as old as my or the my son is as old as
I am now I will be 82 which is to say
Dead uh most likely so in comedy mostly
yeah yeah yeah
McDonald's last night so
um so that stuff is scary and you start
to do like my parents were so young my
parents had me really young which is
probably why I'm [__] up but like when
I was my dad was my age I was like a
senior in high school yeah or maybe
older than that so that stuff is on my
mind all the time but um it's a lot of
math when you do that yeah but it's also
like you
I talk about it I think about it for a
few minutes and then you're like all
right well it is what it is I mean this
is you have to accept and this is when
we had a kid and we struggled for a long
time to have a kid we started trying a
few years ago which was still late and
uh yeah they kept they kept you know the
last thing too I remember when um my
daughter's mother and I we were talking
about having a baby is like
it took three tries right which is quick
some people we've had friends that have
done that as well like my brother the
fir their first child took them like a
year you know it could be years before
you it blows me away that there are
billions of humans and it's really not
that easy
to make one that's what's Wild isn't it
because numbers would would say opposite
I always find it fascinating because
people there's all these accidental
pregnancies and teens what I think it is
if you don't want it that's when it's
coming when you really want it
it's like that Zen [__] like if you try
to sink you float if you try to float
you sing We have um a friend who her
parents were told they couldn't have
children
um they try and try and try it so they
adopted two
and after they adopted they went and had
sex had a baby I keep hearing stories
and it was all that stress and anxiety
of you know you can't you can't and once
they right felt fulfilled and relaxed
and just let it go they had a baby so
she's the only biological of the three
and she's the youngest but you know and
the favorite I imagined absolutely all
the money goes to her all the money yeah
no it's like you have to let go this is
funny because we we had trouble getting
pregnant because first we thought you
know we didn't do any research we're
idiots we're Comics so we're just
[__] so we were just like all right
take out your uh IUD or IED whatever
it's called they rip that out we start
[__] I'm like great you'll get
pregnant in no time they rip that out we
start [__] you'll get pregnant in no
time yeah it doesn't work out that way
and so we did it for like a year and she
did get pregnant and we lost the baby
which was you know devastating yeah it
happened a couple times which was a
bummer honestly how far along you were
getting not too far fortunately beyond
the first trimester no no we didn't have
any of that it was more like a few weeks
it was like three four weeks or whatever
like
five weeks maybe but still very
upsetting I mean there's some people
that lose them obviously like yeah well
into a pregnancy uh which is more
devastating but yeah it was it was
certainly sad and then you have to start
the whole process over again it takes
time and in our minds we're like our
lives are ticking away so then we
decided to go to a fertility clinic
which side note the fertility clinic is
all comedians there's like one in New
York they're like you're a comedians too
and you look over it looks like a green
room at the Funny Bone it's just like a
row of 40 year old female Comics like
hey
oh just a bunch of [__] uh you know
Comics that trying to make it so you put
everything off but anyways we went and I
have something I never know how to
pronounce this I think it's called
varicochly or verisocial it's it's
varicose veins in your balls okay like
the back of your ball if you look it up
it literally says it looks like a bag of
worms my ball bag is
appalling it's really just the backup
just the back yeah the front front
gorgeous yes beautiful you can eat off
these balls
the back the back it looks like you know
your grandmother's legs or something
it's just it looks like worms it
literally looks like that and I realize
this can you see it or is this just on
the inside when they scan it or do you
see them I could feel it the veins in
there you can feel in the back of your
balls yeah and I was like this is Lumpy
and weird and I had to show my wife and
she's like and I would literally like
because my I don't know about you but my
ball back is like six feet long I can't
I can twist it and look at the back yeah
grab it and twist it around so I was
like oh this is something and it can
even cause some pain like people have
surgery to fix it because it can cause
some discomfort or whatever anyways it
also can cause
um sperm depletion or whatever or what's
that low sperm count yeah so we went to
the fertility clinic and this is how
much it sucks to be a woman we're
sitting there and I was like yeah I have
uh varicose fan and I've read that can
affect your sperm and they're like no
it's her they didn't even look into it
or anything they're like just Peter Pan
just quiet down it's definitely this old
[__] right here
knocked out they were like that would
take your sperm count from 15 000 to
like eleven thousand this is that's what
my doctor said he goes just so you know
a low sperm count is still like yeah
whatever eleven thousand yeah yeah they
were like no don't even bother talking
again it's her so we went and then
there's like IVF like straight IVF I
think is like
hundreds of thousands tons of money and
no guarantee and if it doesn't work you
have to just do it all over again and uh
you know I'm doing well but we're in
comedy I'm like I don't feel comfortable
gambling with a hundred thousand dollars
and so we were kind of just like wow
that sucks because I told us the chances
are like one percent doing the math
which is great because she's 44 at the
time it's one percent to wait to get
pregnant and take it to terms you say a
hundred thousand is that what the actual
cost was and is that out of pocket as
well yeah it's something like that it
might be less or more because we didn't
go that route and then it's up there
like that yeah with a one percent chance
no no I'm sorry one percent if you don't
do that got it got it that's like that's
just us straight we're gonna have sex
and see what happens to get it get
pregnant and take it to term at the age
of 44 is like one percent I see so
that's what which we also felt stupid
because we were like oh we've just been
trying like idiots being like here we go
not knowing it's one in a hundred which
is still something IVF I I forget is it
only to like 40 or something so it's a
huge increase but still a good chance of
not and then we were like ah we can't do
that that's too much and then egg donor
was like this other option and I was
like if you wanna
do that that's up to you I would rather
have it be her genetics also but that
felt like too much money to spend so I
was like it's your decision and she
ultimately wanted to do it she just
wanted to be a mom and the thing to me
about egg donor is yeah she's carrying
them it's in her bot so to me it's just
her baby so they take your sperm yeah
fertilize the Egg of another person yeah
so you buy the eggs okay which is much
cheaper it was like 20 000 which is not
nothing
and it's so wild to me that there's this
whole setup for this at different tiers
right right it's like a patreon
[Laughter]
it's crazy well if you got the money you
could do this or there's this but then
there's this down here too you want the
bronze package yeah exactly you can get
some lady you don't know yeah so that
was because then we decided to go
egg donor which is funny because you
have to go and like choose from the
people they give you the baby photos of
egg donor people oh so you're not
getting the adult photo you're getting
their baby photo well you do once you
buy the egg you get an adult photo
what's going on it's so weird dude this
is like some kind of Snapchat [__] or
something it's so bizarre and it feels
like a dating app but it's like chill
the Tinder profile over here it feels
creepy you're literally like swiping on
little kids and they have like pigtails
and they're like impressive to how old
are they showing you the original
pictures like baby baby
four five years old because I think they
want to give you a set at least
something I was gonna say a newborn who
the hell looks like that when they get
to four or five right yeah no it was
like maybe a five or six year old girl
or so and um so you get someone that
kind of looks somewhat like your wife I
guess and then it has all like I mean to
play soccer is going to school for this
because a lot of them are going to call
college and they're trying to pay their
way and they do extensive background
checks and all that stuff and then you
do
um
Health background whatever uh if you're
I forget all the words I'm really dumb
it's okay but um you know if you if
you're flagged for certain diseases or
whatever you guys both match up if you
have that Gene and so it's kind of
straight because it almost feels like
cheating in a weird way I'm like picking
out a woman for our [__] to yeah maybe
you sort of pick like this Superwoman so
to speak yeah and you're like well we
want to actually jeans athletes yeah
yeah no pre uh no pre uh not predisposed
to any that's it yeah yeah like uh BS
yeah yeah so that was um it was exciting
and then we got the woman and then we
got the eggs and it ended up being one
only we're only one was good I don't
know how any of this works it should be
better this was really her story to tell
I just realized in the middle of it I'm
like you should probably have her on
um but yeah so we got the one egg and of
course I have to go jerk off in a cup
which is you know there's a million
stories about it and it's just so so
uncomfortable and do they give you any
fodder in there for your little jerk
session well I had to go twice because I
first time we did it and then for the
reason something had to go something
went wrong yeah well it's also hilarious
we were laughing too because the doctor
is like gorgeous and my wife and I both
meant the same joke of like what could
you just Joe's back you don't even have
to do anything just chill just like
maybe diagnose me with something look at
my varicose vein yeah look at the back
of my ball
in there and the first time I went it
had like a screaming and there was porn
on there which I'm not a big porn guy
um so I was kind of like going through I
was like oh this is great but I realized
I'm just flipping through porn with like
no erection whatsoever just business
like like the way you look at Netflix
what should I watch yeah I don't like
missionaries I'm like that's interesting
and anyways you get it done and then
time had passed they wanted a fresher
sample for whatever reason so I had to
go back again and the second time there
was no porn but there was literally like
Disney plus and Netflix
yeah exactly I'm like I guess baby Yoda
is cute the new sigura special is up
there
that's funny maybe I could
um so I ended up just looking at my
phone and [__] but um yeah it's it's
awkward and um and then you have to you
know put it behind a thing and
it was weird but anyways it all worked
out yeah so can I ask so your sperm goes
into this egg this egg goes into your
wife I get that that egg is from someone
else and that genetics lie in there but
once you put it in your wife nothing
from her penetrate like there's listen
again but I would feel like if we're
moving this thing into this thing
some of this things things gotta get in
there is there really no genetic link at
all I guess not but that's how I feel
I'm like isn't your blood and yeah all
your everything all your fluids
everything that's happening in there but
diet and disposition and all that stuff
I mean I'm a big I think so much of
human behavior is learned behavior from
parents and obviously genetics are a big
role but I know like my cousin is so
much like his he has a stepdad it's not
his biological dad I don't know a father
and son more similar
[Music]
he was two or whatever I mean like
personality traits Behavior sense of
humor so
to me I don't know and she's
do it she's had some emotion with it
it's not easy but I think she's fully
accepted once that baby is in you it's
fully your baby how could it not be yeah
you're I mean you're bringing an egg
to life yeah how could it not be your
baby I mean it's literally and I mean
I'm like oh she's like six months
pregnant right now I'm like having fun
in the sun by the way I've been in La
for two weeks I'm just living it up I'm
like it was the best night ever and
she's like I'm telling all the wrong
facts about it and [__] I couldn't be
less more I could be more removed from
this child of mine so yeah I mean it's
her they're together for nine full
months so this is also funny by the way
so you have to eventually you have to
tell your son that like you know you're
a egg donor baby and we know we've
talked to a couple people that our egg
donor babies themselves that are adults
now
so you go to like a counselor because
they do a lot of counseling and
everything to make sure you're feeling
good and all that and she goes now
eventually you'll have to tell the baby
now and this pissed me off so bad she
presents it to us what age do you think
you should bring it up to your son like
this and I go
I don't know 15. and she's like this
no no no and I'm like well why don't you
just tell me the number instead of
mail and when they're like four or five
when they're really young kids so it's
not a shock later in life which again
I'm like well just [__] tell me that
you [__] you're you're a psychologist
yeah now I just feel like an idiot like
duh I don't know so anyways but it was
so we're supposed to I guess when kids
first start asking I shouldn't have
called her a [__] I appreciate her I
feel bad she's not gonna watch this but
we're not gonna edit it
um no but so you know they're just
supposed to when the kids become
interested in where babies come from I
guess and that way I guess if a teenager
you tell them it's a little more
shocking or like what my whole life is a
lie so you kind of plant the seed in
their head as a kid it seems very
confusing and difficult I'm having a
hard time with it right now I wouldn't
know as a dad of an eight-year-old right
now I don't
she would have already known Now by four
uh three or four years and I'm just like
I don't know if I would drop that on
somebody I guess I understand the point
of not I get it waiting too long but
yeah so I think they won't fully
understand but they'll have this idea of
like well we wanted you so bad and your
mom was old as [__] so and one day
they're gonna go to school where they
have a computer that we didn't and
Google this and look it all up and
understand everything so I don't know
and ultimately they need their to know
their own genetics and all that stuff
listen I'll tell you this you're was it
a psychologist you said or yeah some
kind of yeah I would say by her response
to your the way she set you up like that
I wouldn't listen to anything maybe we
should get a second to pick you up man I
mean it was really like like it was a
setup not a masculate but just like I
was just like fuming I'm like so you
just made me look stupid for no reason
you could have been like and when he's
five yeah
exactly because what if you would have
said four or five which you said yes
very good very good all right dummy
um but yeah so anyways long story show
we're very excited and it's taken so
long it feels that much more um
meaningful and exciting so can I ask you
this the donor do you meet the donor do
you and and does the donor have rights
to visit the child see the child or any
how does that work and you don't have to
answer any of this if you're not
supposed to I'm not you're in trouble I
don't I'm like fully ignorant towards
that and my wife would know better you
should have a ranch great guest
um yeah I don't
I don't know I'm really it's okay I
think that they might I don't know how
it works because I'm sure she had to
sign a bunch of paperwork when she
donated it guys I know a couple Comics
that used to donate sperm for money and
um a lot less money than women get
because there's 75 000 sperm in each
ball or whatever so good point but yeah
I've brought that up with him I'm like
so you might have children around he's
like yeah I guess so
um but I think eventually the the kid
can content I actually understand well I
mean the kids 18 is going to be able to
do whatever your child wants to do right
right yes yeah it's not like there's
gonna be a hiding and you're also
telling
do you know what you're having a boy so
you're also telling him
from four or five that this is how you
came to to be right
um so he's gonna naturally be curious
wouldn't you I would yeah of course I'm
like what well also once you get the the
egg donor you get an adult photo and
she's a gorgeous woman so I wouldn't
mind
so wait yeah that's when you get the
adult oh yeah then they send a tasteful
nude just so you can really see
see what that body is works like uh no
and she was tasteful it's just like a
headshot thing and yeah she's gorgeous
and seems very nice and and you haven't
met her though personally no no I don't
think we meet her okay I don't think oh
man I don't know I should have more
information but I'm just excited about
it once I don't actually think about the
donor thing that much once it's just I
have a pregnant wife there and I love
her and I'm excited for the baby and
it'll be well I imagine also with the
um trauma of losing a baby you're just
stoked that this is working and
happening now yeah yeah this is as far
as we've gone and we keep going and
they're like everything's healthy and
it's
her age is not nearly as much of a
factor now because we're working with a
young donor and the baby's been
um tested and all the ultrasound and all
that stuff so the baby's looking healthy
so how old's the donor shoot at the time
of donuts she was 26. oh okay yeah right
so you have a 26 year old egg in a 45
year old body yes and boom 40 year old
come and 40 year old come yeah mixing
all together yeah put it together and
you got a nice uh kid so yeah hopefully
he
um it'll all be gravy very excited so
let me ask you do I have a bunch of
questions sure if science doesn't exist
and you aren't able to have a child like
I don't know in the 60s yeah what uh you
adopt
I don't know we were not that into the
idea but first of all adoption is I
think really difficult in a lot of that
arduous process and I'm always I always
joke about this I make in my podcast
I've made so many pedophile jokes just
like offhand where I'm like all right
take care subscribe kiss your mother
[__] a kid I mean like just stuff like
that where I'm like if they did any
research I have made 350 million
Millions they're gonna be like this is
psychotic we can't give up a child to
this human being
um but I think it's a really long hard
process and um
I don't know we I guess we would have
thought about that if but we did this
before we got to that option but it
seems very difficult to adopt did you
guys talk about the even this not
working and still being you know
completely fulfilled and that's what the
way it's going to be for you yeah well
I'm pretty good about accepting all my
uh neurosis and anxiety comes from
worrying about the future once things
are happening I'm like all right well
that's what has happened so I think we
talked about the herpes last time yeah
once you get it you're like all right
well I guess that's that so we're this
time too this is our one because we only
had one egg so we were like let's do it
and whatever happens happens
and to me it's like
I'm a relative Optimist I'm like if it
doesn't work out you know we'll travel
and keep living the lives really we're
living a very full life as is and um you
know I've been doing well so I'm like we
have my not having kids is fun too you
can kind of especially if you're doing
well financially I'm like we can go off
to
Paris or wherever and you know there's
still a fulfilling life to be had but
I'm definitely happy it's working out
this way what are you looking most
forward to about being a dad
um
boy I really well I have nieces and
nephews that really it sounds like so um
try it or wear but like I feel like you
really feel like seen and heard as a as
a
Father Figure an uncle where like the
kids are like wow that's great and you
can feel the difference of like
connection like I feel my nieces and
nephews I can feel like that I've gotten
through to them which is so difficult
and you just feel this feeling of like
wow they really appreciate me and I love
them and there's this connection and I
feel meaningful to them it gives you it
does give you meaning to be around
children even children that aren't mine
I'm not even related to gives me the
most fulfilling feeling the things I'm
most proud of in my life are
relationships with my nieces and nephews
so I imagine I can only imagine that a
kid is that much greater and then
obviously when like I'm big into sports
I imagine my kid will be as well and
um all those things the catch and I
think also making not I don't want to
say making up but being the father that
I didn't have
I had a father but the being in the way
that I would have liked what sort of
that was your dad my dad's a he's a good
dad I want to talk disparaging of my dad
but very Boston Irish Catholic stoic not
a lot of um
emotion not a lot of emotion not a lot
of communication very little
in response we talk about the socks for
about 10 minutes maybe the Patriots
that's right yeah there's no um so he's
still alive now yeah he's still around
very funny guy comes to shows laughs
funny funny guy is he still with your
mom yeah yeah there you go are you
talking to him about being a dad
no that's not happening do you want to
yeah yeah what would happen if you just
called him was like Dad I got a bunch of
questions about being a father you got
an hour it's what if you just said that
I keep thinking this this is like on my
list of things to do this what my
therapist talks about a lot he's like
call him my therapy impression
I tried I've been in therapy for years
now I tried calling my dad one time
years ago I mean we've literally never
talked to the phone we'll text a little
bit okay zero is not a day to day or
even weekly communication you would say
you just see him when you see him is
that sort of thing yeah I see him if I
go up to but they're in Boston or
Massachusetts when I go up there they're
around he doesn't come visit here no my
parents do not come over New York excuse
me my mother is afraid of bridges
that's her excuse and what about before
I come to New York I've lived in New
York of course I know I've lived in New
York for 17 years I grew up in
Massachusetts so it's 200 miles they've
come three times my appendix erupted I
did Letterman and I got married those
are the three that's it visits yeah
they've never been like we're coming
down to New York mom's not yeah her or
less I think my dad would more but she's
just filled with anxiety and how many
brothers and sisters do you have one
older sister one older sister okay and
are they more affectionate or open with
her no so it's not just this guy to guy
thing you know he's the son whatever no
it's just very my my mother's my parents
love language is more like my dad like
if I
you know I'll I'll drive up to
Massachusetts my dad will take the car
to get an oil change while I'm still in
bed they wake up early and he's like got
the oil changed
that's what I get yeah I don't get
congrats on the kids yeah like vibe
there has been no discussion of yeah
three thousand more on that yeah enjoy I
even put the sticker in the thing you
know or my mother buys like uh Joe he
loves DiGiorno we got DiGiorno's opens
the freezer yeah not a lot of like we're
so proud of you or anything like that
but you know they're doing the best they
can or whatever but um
yeah it's on your list of things to do
to call them and talk to them before
your son's born yeah I've had this
thought because how when does your son
due October 29th it's coming man but
yeah so I called him once when I was in
therapy and I I was like Hey and he was
like what like what it throws him off
and I was like yeah you know I always
just like the call will be like is he
worried that you're about to tell him
some horrible news or something because
it's I always joke I'm like if I see my
dad's number I'm like my mom died
I call my parents Deb and Steve like
they're and I have since I was a kid ah
I swear to God so I was like 13.
Steve and your mom dad yes that's not
even their names which is weird
yeah I mean it's
I don't know and we're like you ever hug
you hug we hugged I started hugging
after therapy I was like hey we don't
hug and they kind of put it on me
because I've always been like
you know yeah hugging's gay or whatever
I was gonna say after he hung up with
you he's probably like our son's gay
yeah our son's 100 gay he wants a hug so
I was just like you know we should start
hugging and saying I love you we never
really do that with your dad on the
phone no I said it like to my mom on the
phone and then she tells my dad I kind
of communicate with my dad through my
mother and what is your mom's response
to that
um she's like okay like this is weird
it's cool it's very um
it's very strange that is interesting
are you an affectionate man with your
wife do you cuddle do you like yeah big
time yeah I really love to snuggle and
Spoon and do you see yourself being an
affectionate dad with your son oh yeah I
think I'm gonna be crying all the time
a lot of kissing you will bro you get to
go get your non-stop you're like okay
yeah well like I said I'm like I have um
I have a niece and my sister's kids who
are 18 and 15 now and then my best
friend's kids are 11 and 7 and there he
named his kid after me which is really
nice touching and
um they call me Funko Joe I have like a
a deep relationship with them and I'm
like
my nephew is we share a name so I feel
very connected to him but I'm like
he says stuff that I'm like I can't
believe you're why I remember when you
were born this is great like I'm so
proud Blown Away by him like he used a
sentence where he said for example like
he was playing some games he's like what
if we played a game where you pick a
color for example and just him saying
for example I started crying I was like
for example where'd you get that my
daughter's eight years old it's a 12
minute ride to her mom's house last
night she freestyle wrapped an entire
[__] song about the solar system
I couldn't get over it and it was good I
was like God what what yeah and I'm like
she's like give me another planet Dad
I'm like Pluto she's like it's not a
planet we argue about that I'm like fine
Neptune and she'll go on a whole rap
about Neptune and so I'm like I'd say it
all the time I'm like you used to just
cry and pee and poop right that's all
you would do no it's mind-blowing it's
it's it's Discovery in your home bro
yeah and it's and you weren't even there
for so long and then you were there and
now you're created a soul out of
well that's what I struggle with
sometimes because you know I I'm like
I'm doing very well like you know I did
the Wilbur Theater in Boston my hometown
and like it sold out and my family they
come they do come and I think they laugh
but I'm like
aren't you like Blown Away aren't you
like what the [__] that's crazy I
remember you said you want to do comedy
when you were nine ah but they just kind
of go all right DiGiorno take care
exactly how's the oil yeah exactly and
um there's no real like yeah and I think
if I was like are you guys proud of it
like of course yeah why are you even
asking what a silly question so and like
the the kid there just feels like
inherent to them that it of course all
these things we just don't verbalize or
or emotionally show you that I think so
and again it's learned behavior that's
what they got you know I think my dad's
was my dad played catch with me and
everything and came to all my games so I
think that was more than his dad did
right so it's like so I've already I'm
already yeah today yeah I'm there
um but yeah they have not really said
like I've lived past 42 so I feel like
I'm better than my dad you know what I
mean I've already done a better job
right yeah and I got eight years on them
well so I I think they think
you know
we're we're at the show I bet I'm having
a kid they have not said like we're so
excited why are you registered can we
come out to help the register they've
asked about like coming my mother's been
like yeah I can't the New York the
bridges and it's just too much I'm like
okay I guess fear of bridges greater
than love of child and grandchild is
there no route with GPS these days to
get from Boston to New York without a
bridge like I said I'm like you can do
the tunnel you could go through yeah
I guess you still have to go to the GW I
guess you could go west it'd be like a
10 hour trip I don't know you could go
West and down and then take the tunnel
or you know just close your eyes on the
bridge we've got an eye mask on for 10
seconds I have a couple cocktails yeah
um knock you out on the way and or fly I
live 10 minutes from LaGuardia they can
also fly LaGuardia that would be Bridge
free can I just say this why don't you
just [__] tell them I bought you
tickets they're booked here's what I
want you to come yeah that's what I
could do my therapist says I should make
them work for the relationship
be like all right well I guess you can
see the kid whenever or be like you're
coming down you [__] [__] yeah at
least when when he's born I would think
yeah it'd be nice to have your parents
there yeah also let Grandma and Grandpa
hold him for a couple hours while you
take a nap you're gonna be wiped dude
yeah yeah it's a lot going on I'm
already tired I did four shows left yeah
baby can't forget about it no you got a
Baby Dude wait till you have to start
booking sitters and how much they cost
and all that I know it's terrifying
let's go back I'm just so curious about
your parents so
are you gonna call your dad and have
this conversation I got a
TR I keep meaning to and my dad he's
about to have a surgery on his um fate
he had like a dental thing that [__]
up his sinuses and [__] and he has to
have surgery and we did have a moment
we're in Maine a couple weeks ago on
vacation and just kind of out of the
blue he was like yeah I gotta have a
serious surgery they they put you uh out
and uh I'm nervous about it I was gonna
say he must have been worried about it a
month before my babies so I think like
Oh and it throws you off you know when
someone behaves differently you're kind
of like what
that's the weird thing about not showing
emotion for so long because then when
somebody does you're like oh
I'm not ready for this and I kind of
took me
about I was like oh wow yeah well that's
crazy well I think it'll be okay and I'm
actually driving up there because again
my mother the surgery is in Boston they
live in the suburbs and my mother's like
I can't drive into the city she's just a
terrified person so I was like I'll tell
you what I'll come up there and I'll
drive I love driving into the city so
that feels like service I'll come and be
there in my mind I'm like before he goes
under maybe I'll be like I love you pop
or something but um when he wakes up
you'll be there for him yeah exactly so
you know what you could say when he's
there you could say you know what you
know what really is scaring me lately
having this kid can I talk to you about
that and there's a hostage in that bed
boy you got him he's strapped in you got
him yeah he's like you know Jimmy
Stewart's real window he can't he's
laying there dude you got him so I think
like that'll probably be more open to
talking to you I know when I was on all
those pain meds I was saying all kinds
of stuff yeah I would have talked to you
about anything you wanted to hear about
no I remember when I had my uh appendix
surgery I was this you know you're in
such a sensitive place I remember Like
Home Alone was on I was like sobbing
and then like Rocky came on after and
Rocky the scene where he's like I just
want to prove I'm not just another bum
from the neighborhood I was like
appendicitis you dork
but oh man you know you're invulnerable
spots yeah
but yeah so I I gotta I gotta uh try and
that's what's hard too because I think
this all the time my dad and I would go
to Sox games as a kid and I always
wonder I'm like
was that fun were you pumped were you
dreading it I have no concept because
when you're a kid everything's just
normal it is what it is so I was like
this is the best and I'm sure he must
have some fond memories of going to the
ball games but I it is mysterious he
would have gone back if he didn't right
right you know what I mean yeah no and
that was we really
connected over that and um it's
interesting too it's also a great place
to take someone to show them what
emotions are right home runs and people
going crazy yeah there's a you're losing
or you're booing there's a lot of stuff
going on there without him having to
show you any emotion whatsoever exactly
and that's the greatest thing about the
sport of emotion yeah you can really
connect uh through that and it's that's
the beautiful thing about sports bonding
Fathers and Sons especially baseball
because if it's every day and in and out
in the seasons and all that but
yeah we'll see I gotta try to call and
be like hey yeah I understand you're
nervous I'm nervous too what were you
you know wonder what he was most scared
about
yeah I mean he's probably had you in his
20s yeah he was he had my sister he was
I think 19 and 23 when he had me I mean
my mother's two years younger so yeah
that's what's yeah I mean like I said he
was my age I was already 18 years old
right so and he must have been um
I don't know scared shitless and anxious
and I don't know I don't know what he
thought yeah because he doesn't tell you
yeah it's all just never told you
guessing yeah and that you know
obviously plays so funny because my
dad's dead I wish I could ask him those
questions right I wish I could be like
and also I'm a twin I'm like yeah two at
the same [__] time like what was that
like you know what are you thinking what
was that like that kind of [__] I want
to know well that's the thing that makes
me sad in my life is my I'll be around
other parent like my wife's parent her
dad's gone now but they had such
enthusiasm when they were kids they were
like I remember we would used to take
you to camp we all and would sit in a
circle and belly laughing about like
remember that that was crazy you guys
were so my parents just don't tell any
stories of like well I remember when you
were five you used to this or that
there's just not a lot of that or we
would get excited about this or they
just don't talk like that is your sister
more emotional openly emotional as a mom
with her kids than your parents were
with her I think so yeah I think so
so yeah so age seems to be a big worry
for you with this yeah definitely I feel
you on that I used to think the same
thing I'm like hmm 41 so when you
graduate 51 and 8 it will be 59 yes and
people are definitely going to be like
is this your grandpa right right listen
little [__] well here
these days at least in California it's
you see so many more older parents yeah
I think it's becoming more normal I
worry about energy and physicality like
I'm a really like uh Bountiful energy
guy I like jumping around and playing
basketball and pickleball and tennis and
hiking and I worry that like I don't
want to be the dad that's like you go or
I'm trying to play catch and I'm like
throwing like I'm leading with the elbow
because my rotator cuff is so I'm trying
to
stretch and all that stuff and try to be
a bit healthier because
it would I don't want to be just a total
shadow of myself when he's the age of of
playing and stuff so that worries me of
like he's playing baseball and I'm like
I can't have a catch with you but I'll
exactly so that stuff is you know I'm
trying to take care of myself so I can
do that
we'll see
I don't know I I it's here's the other
thing too I think it's more something
you're seeing more these days because
first of all it's so much more expensive
to survive on this planet these days and
if you're having a kid in your 20s when
you're still either in college or paying
for college or you couldn't afford to go
like you're you're saddled with an
expensive burden I'm just being honest
in your 20s
I mean good luck I think the reason
people waiting more now is they're able
to get a job they're able to start a
career they're able to save some money
and sort of think about you know do I
really want to do this do it can I
afford this I mean I'll say this unless
you're a [__] bazillionaire there's
never enough money to you know you're
never ready right there's no number
where you're gonna hit and place you're
gonna be or anything go now it's exactly
time for it's not us you know we're not
launching a space shuttle yeah it's kind
of difficult though to have but I just
mean no that's that's I'm always worried
about that too because like right now
I'm doing well financially but you know
comedy is such all businesses now
especially with [__] AI it feels like
there's no like um job security anyway
but that feeling of like oh it's like
kids get really a new babies like not
that much more expensive it's like
you've got diapers and hopefully they
breastfeed whatever you can just bite
off some of your food and here take that
but like when they're 14 15 playing
travel baseball for Less whatever wait
till you see how much it costs now for
little leagues and other stuff they have
to do and all the school stuff yeah man
it's way more than we you're gonna be
like we didn't get my daughter goes to a
summer camp at the beach
and she's like Dad what did you do for
summer camp in the summer and I said we
went outside I didn't go to any [__]
Camp right it was go out ride your bike
play sports find your friends you know
all that stuff and then be back before
dark like it was I didn't go I went to
one Camp my whole entire life it was a
soccer camp Bucknell University I kept
the jersey for a while I was a I was the
red color team against Blue my brother
was on green there was a blue and
another one
we won we won the whole thing oh nice
kept my little Trophy and everything uh
but no [__] camps yeah I did ever did
you go to Camp to baseball camp at
Massasoit Community College but it was
you know one time or every summer I went
I think like two or three Summers but it
was five days and you didn't sleep there
you just it was down the street they
drop you off you play baseball at the
community college you come back
um but there was no like we're going to
whatever Jason Voorhees camp or whatever
I can't press the lake yeah Crystal Lake
there you go yeah we didn't do
um yeah we didn't do any of that stuff
but I always talk about I'm like you
know it sounds so weird like back in my
day but yeah I had a key in my shoe and
yeah and you biked around and then
eventually your parents would yell up
the street sweaty [__] dollar bills
and tucked in your sock yeah biking
around I used to hate that I'm like why
is this money wet let's swim uh Shin
sweat all over it yeah always just wet
fives
um is your wife what is your wife's
biggest concerns right now about having
a baby I don't know I don't really talk
to her uh no you're just like your dad
um I don't know right now she has just
been extremely excited first of all I
keep saying this my wife makes every
pregnant woman I've ever met sound like
a whiny [__] my wife is loving it she's
just have she I mean she's in the second
trimester which you know is is the the
good spot I guess
but she was nauseous a bunch in the
first tournament but never really got
sick and she's been like running we
played pickleball and
she's she's been good and she's just
really excited I think her main concern
is what her career will look like with
having a baby because she's a comic
and it's hard because
you know I've just been fortunate to be
a bit more financially successful in the
business so it becomes hard where it's
like
it's going to be harder to go on the
road and we'd go on the road together a
bunch she would open for me but it's
harder to both on the road if you have a
baby yeah and you don't want to you want
to bring two incomes into that family
yeah and it's hard too because it's like
for her to go on the road it's like I
have to stay home if she's gonna go on
the road but I do uh at the time being
right now pretty well on the road so
it's I think she's worried about that
um that's like her main concern is just
kind of like what does my career look
like now which obviously both of them
will have to take a step back while we
try to raise him just for a second
you'll figure it out yeah I thought the
same thing I thought there's no way I'm
gonna be a single parent that has my
daughter half the time fully invested
and make comedy and stuff work I freaked
out about that right
you just to make it work yeah you kind
of have to figure it out yeah you chased
a dream of being a stand-up comedian
look at you now you figured it out it's
just that's what you do you just figure
it the [__] out well that's listen to
everyone and no one right you know what
I'm saying everyone's gonna give you
advice well swaddle well this kid might
love to be swaddled this one might hate
to be [__] right swaddled even your
own siblings could be different like
right just my only advice is figure out
whatever works best for YouTube and or
three excuse me and do that right that's
it yeah you just kind of navigate it
like anything else I guess it's um yeah
it's funny because I'm like well comedy
such a hard job with the kid because you
go on the road you have to leave and
then someone a comic that I know is a
parent was like no it's the best he's
like yeah you leave Friday Saturday but
you're home all day Monday Tuesday
Wednesday like you have boundful time
available tons so
let's see yeah we just make it work it's
yeah it's one of those things of like
it's like that old thing uh how do you
make God laugh you tell them your plans
for the future it's like yeah there's
nothing I don't know what it will look
like but we'll figure it out yeah you'll
figure it out we'll see well congrats
dude thanks man um this has been great
I've loved talking to you about this
yeah me too um plug and promote
everything again please
um comediennejolist.com for dates I have
two podcasts I have Tuesdays with
stories with Mark Norman I have another
podcast called mindful Metal Jacket
which is similar to this it's a lot of
mindfulness and therapy stuff and um
that's on YouTube they're both on
YouTube and then I have a brand new
special called enough for everybody on
my YouTube and it's a follow-up to one
that came out last year called this
year's material and there's another one
from two years ago called I hate myself
so three specials all on YouTube all
free all right yeah uh go watch Joe's
special as always Ryan sickler on all
social media get your tickets for the
tour at ryansickler.com we'll talk to
you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
please